not gonna lie people what i really want
to do right now
is hum the theme song and the ending
credits of godzilla versus kong but
yeah dude monetize was stupid as crap
don't even think about it
and already i'm like well i don't know
we're kind of risking him covering this
trailer but i mean i hear the title and
i'm like
i gotta risk it godzilla versus kong
china tv spot mechagodzilla
reveal
[Music]
whoa
these are dangerous times
godzilla's out there and he's hurting
people and we don't know why
we need kong the world needs them
we need them to fight through the
entrance in antarctica we could help
them find a new home
oh do that entrance in antarctica we
could help find any homes that they said
yeah has some new footage in here the
myths are real
there was a war
and they're the last one standing
[Music]
the love tap who vows for who
kong bows
oh i saw some wings in there
oh break that chain
there he
[Music]
wow talk about visual confirmation like
none other not even mechagodzilla in the
eye
or the directors coming out was as much
of a confirmation
are literally a terminator jazz going on
right here
wow look at them spikes yeah so that
design that leak design that we saw
which you can check out that video from
3c films that we covered this looks like
it's
that's what it is yeah it looks pretty
accurate yeah
i mean from all that reveal that they
did in the set visit
i mean it certainly seems like they're
not concerned holy crap
that is awesome yeah i'm excited man so
uh very recently
i watched godzilla vs mechagodzilla the
very first
original one have you seen it yeah 70s
no no no 1936.
way back before the code it was super
violent
but no yeah i i didn't catch that one i
was like i gotta watch the original one
and all i want to say is as excited as i
am
for this movie coming out if there's not
even a hint
at gorilla aliens showing up
in this franchise yeah i'm gonna be very
upset this is a perfect
opportunity to expand that mythology and
bring in even more beloved
characters and creatures what kind of
metal is this uh mechagodzilla could be
made out of they better reveal that
apex what are aliens yeah yeah
or yeah were founded by some alien means
or whatever
be awesome i doubt they'll do it but
as far as this goes this is a pretty
awesome trailer so they're saying
through the entrance
in antarctica we can help them find a
new home so i'm assuming
that wait i'm so confused because
there's some shots in the chair that
make it look like they're picking him
up from there and bringing him here but
i'm like wait is it going to end were
they helping find a new home through
there at the very end after
said fight is complete maybe i mean it
would be
interesting maybe like skull island has
been destroyed and the entrances to the
hollow earth that could have existed
there are gone
i don't know really what to expect in
terms of when that'll pop up in the
movie but i can't imagine
kong necessarily just shacking up in the
coldest place on earth
you know but if that's the only hope and
if there's some kind of like
other take on the hollow earth that's
more frigid you know that could be cool
because i'm also sitting here thinking
like they have to have some surprises
still for us or or no i mean so i don't
need it
even that is is another reveal but at
least it's hinting towards like oh maybe
there's other stuff down there
we might be able to watch this on friday
and if we're able to
i'm hoping i get all this room for me
before i go watch this movie
i hope the whole thing leaks on twitter
someone just sent us the whole movie all
right guys
which team are you
subscribe click that notification bell
i'm going out of town next week
hopefully i can cover this before then
see you guys